and how old were you when you started
eighteen eighteen yes when I turn 18 I
was April of 2008
so I started right as the market had
peaked and was starting to go down and
that's when I jumped in Wow and how did
you start or how did you transition into
making YouTube videos and like sharing
your what knowledge of money and finance
you know honestly that was something
I've wanted to do for quite some time I
just never had the courage to do it I
really believed like who is gonna watch
me who would care what I had to say and
I said that for years like I wanted to
make youtube videos back in 2011 because
I had watched YouTube as my TV's since
like 2010 and I had seen all these
channels come up from nothing and
thinking like this is something I really
want to do when I see the potential in
doing this yeah and after three four
years of telling myself that like no one
would watch me I posted a random video
about how I got started selling real
estate I filmed that at an open house
that was slow that day and I posted it
on YouTube not thinking anything of it
but I had such a good time doing that
that I figured well let me just make
another one and after that you know I
started getting a few subscribers maybe
got like two or three subscribers at the
time and I kept posting videos and I
started giddy you know finally starting
to get some sort of views and I remember
when my videos would hit like a hundred
views of video and to me that was like
the biggest deal in the world that like
a hundred people on the planet saw my
video mmm and I kept posting and then
randomly about three months into it I
had one of my videos just take off and
YouTube started recommending that video
on the home page of YouTube for people
that were searching for real estate and
that video went from like I think it was
at maybe a thousand views at the time
maybe two thousand views all the way to
like three hundred thousand views in
about a week and that took me from out
of 500 subscribers to 32,000 within
about a month and a half and then I
posted another video on how I make
rental income like passive income and
that got me from 32 to 50 thousand
subscribers and that was enough to
really get my initial wave on YouTube
and then at that point I was like holy
crap like now I'm actually making money
by doing this with the ad revenue and
now I see the potential and and so I
just continue doing that and and now
that income
it's just skyrockets it's almost you
know a hundred times to when I was
making back then it's just insane on
your first video correct me if I'm wrong
but it was you were talking about how
you became a millionaire at 26 and what
did you do you taught people how to be a
millionaire at like a young age that
video was more so just telling my story
okay there was nothing to sell in that
video is literally just this is what I
did mm-hmm
and these are some of the things that
you can learn from my experiences doing
that um but basically that video summed
up is that I saved everything I made
mm-hmm working as a real estate agent I
was the cheapest person alive I saved up
money for about three and a half four
years invested in real estate in 2011
fixed up those properties rented them
out those properties went up in value I
continued saving all the money I made as
a real estate agent continued investing
and then I'm sure after about seven
years of doing that I had a million
dollar net worth and that was just
before I turned 26 and you made all this
money from commissions on selling houses
so I got involved as a real estate agent
initially leasing property so I would
find because because that would to me at
the time was a really underserved market
was leasing so I would lease people
their houses I'd maybe make a thousand
bucks maybe two thousand dollars by
doing this no other agent wanted to
waste their time doing leasing because
why would they make a thousand dollars
when they can make twenty thousand
selling a home but I would take all of
these clients and there's no competition
for me back then it was just I was so
happy to make a thousand dollars being
like eighteen or nineteen years old like
to me that may have been a hundred grand
so what ended up happening though is
after about three years a lot of these
lease clients ended up coming back to me
and saying hey we want to buy a house
now and you're our agent and so all of
these one to two thousand dollar
commissions started turning into twenty
to fifty thousand dollar checks and then
they would tell their friends about me
and all of a sudden one lease client
could gave me like five other sales and
I've had one lease client that I did
though I think it was like a $3,500 a
month lease I maybe made $1,200 from
doing that they've at least giving me
seven or eight clients for sale and now
that that's easily got to be worth over
200 grand from one client I did
for lease so it just kept snowballing
and kept snowballing and that's how I
was able to come up as a real estate
agent